tesla shares are falling today as
production snags stall delivery of
Tesla's Model X also the company's
founder Elon Musk says the problems
could affect the output of Tesla's Model
S sedans are falling on the news down
more than eight and a half percent on
the conference call one investor asked a
different question would a tesslar uber
partnership make any sense my co-host in
the next half hour Betty Lewis here with
more Betty and him that led to one of
the most awkward moments during the
conference call I mean generally a
conference call with Elon Musk is a
little awkward because he answers
questions very long he takes long pauses
and but this was a very awkward moment
and I'll just read to you what happened
so Morgan Stanley analyst Adam Jonas who
covers Tesla a very good analyst asked
him look you know what a Tesla uber
partnership makes sense because Tesla
wants to dominate the autonomous
automobile market right they predict
tens of thousands of cars that they will
be able to they will be able to make by
the year twenty twenty and that led to
Elon Musk musk saying after a very long
long silence hmm that's an insightful
question more silence then adam said you
don't have to answer it an Elon reply
back I don't think I should answer it so
it led everybody to think maybe there's
a little bit more than just chatter you
know amongst amongst Tesla fans about
this could there really be a sensible
partnership here and you know Travis
kalanick has said before that if and
when Tesla makes these autonomous cars
he wants to buy them he thinks the chief
executive of uber exactly the CEO of
uber there that they would make a great
product for his service in fact any
autonomous vehicle would be a good
product for a ride sharing service like
uber I would imagine that Tesla would be
very happy if they made those middle
seats because that seems to be the
problem with the new model I was going
to say even before we get to autonomous
cars Pym they got to get their model x
ray their SUV which is really geared
towards people like me right the the
soccer mom out there am I going to buy
this I need to make sure it works well
fits my lifestyle well you'll see you'll
have to wait until they start production
all right it